passing to Travis sanheim has been a real
Workhorse on the Philadelphia defense he's
seventh in the league minutes played here's
connec with an early chance and a great save
by the Smith as the Canucks turn it over at the
side of the goal now another shot from the line
goes wide there's a lot going on already here I
talked about the unpredictability of the first
game after Christmas and zadorov burps this
one up behind the net it hits the side of
the net and Casey the Smith now gets a return
pass from coutu here's Frost shooting off the
shoulder of the Smith kept the shoulders up and
now the loose Puck comes to Teddy bler who'll
take his time before chipping it down into
the flyer Zone and heading to the bench on a
change that the Flyers have gone 5 and two
in their last seven Road games is something
because the power play has been very quiet as
York loads up with that one off the blocker
and wide of the goal H glander steps out of the
box conck on the power play for the next minute
25 as the puck is sent through to Smith knocked
it away and now he's able to block the centering
pass Conor Garland takes control of the puck
Hughes to Miller there you see the aggressive
penalty King the conck beat it with a pass to Pon
throws one to the crease who's make chopping at
the puck couldn't make cont and sealer while
Falling Down is able to slide it down the ice
now sealer pass rinson broken up here comes mck
with speed turns on Walker dishes back Pon Kenco
blocked ainson might have saved the goal there
now a shot by heroni and he didn't get much on
it it's into the glove of Arison he'll hang
on for the whistle I mention connecting with
three short-handed goals that's not tied for
the league leag but it is tying his career hot
is what I meant to say nice pass back Noah jwes
Ian Cole with the r shot tip stopped by Aron hson
redirected that one 15 points back of the second
wild card I like his optimism but man that seems
like a lot here's a chance from MAV Aron just
had that one hit him I thinks maintain control
but Jon stripped to the Pucket the blue and here
comes bman on the right wing touch in front and
he ran into the go Cher Bluer line julson will
turn it over they're currently tied for 10th
at 722 here's Hughes with a shot that ticked off
the end of the glove of Arison it went into the
corner ran into zamula as he got to the Blue Line
flyer skate the other way ainson RIS the long one
into smith top of the crease makes that sit and
he'll take the whistle we'll take another break
this game Bas not sure what happened did you
ever figure it out here's [__] with a shot
and the glove saved by Aron who snares that one
and H on to stop play ahead to halfway he leaves
for L Scot L around ref round and to Smith just
got back with the left p man there was a lot of
net there for a moment brilliant work by the
Smith as he's got to react quickly you knows
he's got to go here as lon's around the back of
the net a half a stride in front of Ian colon
in skates Garland digs it free finds Cole who's
able to chip it to the line but not out Walker
left point stealer with a shot to Smith squeezes
that one Flyers try another shot off the draw that
bid by Brick went off is sticking over top of
the goal now it's thrown hard to the crease by
Palin Atkinson Lees for far sifts his
way in passes to forer feeds back jagor
zamula Tyson Forster watched by Pew
Suter here's zamula shoter staying
with him they score zamula Threw It
on goal and if it wasn't tip that's
his second career goal and both of
them have come at the expense of the
Canucks 12 Power Play Goals on the season zula's
goal here really looks kind of a lot like his
first one shorty against thater Demco this is
through a screen the whole way nobody touches
it and zamis shealer faked one way and lost the
puck to besser H Lander from behind the net still
has it but it's knocked away towards connect who
brings the puck out to Center and he'll carry it
over the line feeding one through it comes
right across they score Walker joining the
rush on the right side the defenseman jumping
in and the Flyers with another one an it two
nothing Shan Walker's fourth of the year starts
way behind the net he's in front of the net and
he joins the rush though kaduck are now chasing
the play and the first pass is chipped into the
middle of the ice Walker stays in the far Lane
this is a great play by Owen tippet to keep this
Puck moving zenor had it knocked off his KCK
he goes back to collect Flyers 5 and two in
their last seven Row games here's a turnover
chance for fary and on goal he Geeks and he
scores three quick ones for the Flyers late in
the second and it's three nothing Philadelphia
I talked about being patient in a game where not
much is happening here's an impatient play as the
door off's trying to make something happen this
is a pretty slick move on the Breakaway the 12th
goal of the year for Joel fobby all of them at
five on five the Breakaway drag back around the
right toe of Casey the Smith and the Flyers have
a three spot and a three nothing lead kkny feeds
one through KR was checked following up as KK
knocked off his stick by Myers and Joshua finds
Quinn Hughes who chips one down the left wing
Dakota Joshua cutting towards the goal centers B
scores who else the F line seven game point
streak for Teddy bler and 25 seconds into the
third the conu her on the board shorty we just
talked about making it harder on the opposition
a turnover good play defensively and Quinn huel
just flip this up the boards to Dakota Joshua
who uses his size to get around the defenseman
Travis sanheim and as gluger pulls up because
he's got Garland going to the far post that
creates a triangle of offense two options
for Here Comes paling shorthanded centering
the puck oh to Smith save and they score on
the rebound eighth short-handed goal of the
season for the Philadelphia Flyers as Garnet
hawit puts them back up by three and sucks a
lot of the life out of this building goals in
back-to-back games by Garnet Hathaway Ryan paling
can really skate a free agent signed in p or from
Pittsburgh rather in the offseason paling gets to
the puck and when besser stops up in the middle of
the ice he doesn't take care of halfway on the
back door the Smith makes one save couple of
blocks couple good plays in front of Carter Hart
here's Conor Garland all alone is M stopped by
har Robson on the call so many New Year's Eve
meetings with the Flyers seemed like they were
here every year there's a chance right in
front what an opportunity for Neil Zan easy
call for the official to make here's Neils
Oman a little earlier just pucks up in the
air and he times it coming down and coutura
leaves for tippet dying seconds of the power
PL besser standing in the Box here's Frost
across and a nice save by the Smith there
he had a great chance for a power play goal
here Frost to tip it but to Smith able to make
the save now maybe one last bit from Ian col
feeds it over honic long shot into the glove
of heart he doesn't want to stop play he wants
this one to come to an end and that's what it
will do as the Philadelphia Flyers improve
to 60 and2 in their last eight Road games